what's
biden gonna do with guns and second
amendment is there gonna be a buyback
you know
as president biden will they say second
amendment
he will ban the manufacturing sale of
assault weapons and high-capacity
magazines
reinstate the obama biden policy to keep
guns out of the hands of certain people
unable to manage their affairs for
mental reasons which president
trump reversed biden will enact
legislation prohibiting an individual
who has been convicted of a misdemeanor
hate crime or received an enhanced
sentence for misdemeanor because of hate
or bias
in its commission from purchasing or
possessing a firearm
and the online sale of firearms and
ammunitions
biden will enact legislation to prohibit
all online sales of firearms
ammunition kits and gun parts let me
read that one more time
and the online sale of firearms and
ammunitions biden will enact
legislation to prohibit all online sales
of firearms
ammunition kits and gun parts so
you know mike obviously you're in this
world this is this is what you do as a
navy seal now you're training dogs and
you're one of the best at it you know
people i think you were on 60 minutes i
don't know what it was years ago when
they did a show on you with 60 minutes
2014 2012 13 when they did that yeah
what are your thoughts what do you think
is going to happen with the biden
administration
so to me there's a couple things that it
kind of depends on
which is first and foremost is whether
or not the senate remains in in
republican majority and i think that's
that's really the biggest key to whether
or not he has the ability to do any of
these things because
through or via executive order
i'm not aware or of the understanding
that he can even do that
by himself so to me that you know that's
i think it just highlights how important
the the georgia race is
uh and i also think you know even if if
the tables were turned i think an all
all republican uh you know government
would would be equally
slanted that way in not a good way i
think balance and you know having at
least one of the three
uh branches of of government should be
um you know
opposed so that's first and foremost but
you know from an industry standpoint um
you know that's devastating if if that
does happen
i mean in terms of canceling jobs and
and uh
you know curbing markets uh you know the
firearm and ammo industry is is pretty
significant in this country as as most
people are aware so
uh you know if he tries to do that he's
gonna create a lot of enemies uh
you know ones that he probably already
has but i think that that's going to
have impacts on
on people that are maybe a little bit
unforeseen uh in some of the support
roles or transportation or
uh you know just the the supporting
mechanisms of
of the firearm and ammunition industry
because it's not just that there's gear
there's training courses there's
uh you know hunt hunting lodges i mean
there's a lot of
uh kind of you know subsequent uh
industries that i think uh you know are
gonna be impacted by that but
to me what's frustrating about it is
this is coming from a guy that you know
his
the the two most famous kind of uh you
know sops if you will the standard
operating procedures is
grab a double barrel shotgun and blast
it in the air
and then also saying why don't you just
shoot the guy in the leg like
both of those things highlight just how
woefully
disconnected he is from from people that
carry that for a living and i i have
strong opinions about this
government-wise across the board is that
one of the biggest problems i think this
country has is that so many of our
our high level decisions are being made
by people that know absolutely nothing
about them and it's not just firearms
it's everything
whether it's transportation it's energy
it's foreign policy it's firearms i mean
you name it
is it you know you've got people making
decisions about things that they just
don't know anything about and i think
you know as it relates to firearms if
you want to understand
uh you know not just how they work but
the impacts that they have on society
and
and you know the principles with which
people that carry them for a living
adhere
to you should ask them same thing with
say border patrol is that you know you
should ask
border patrol hey we want the border
secured you tell us what you need to do
that
on firearms you know you should talk to
police officers uh into professional
soldiers people that carry firearms for
a living
and ask them what uh what they think and
i think more more policies need to be
driven by subject matter experts and not
people
that just think that they that they know
what the deal is and i think that that's
the case here
yeah i think it's a perfect segue for
where i can chime in on this
uh speaking of asking the experts you
know i've been guilty of acting
and in my opinion rightfully so very
emotionally
on the gun issue i'm from miami south
florida
over the last few years we saw what
happened in parkland
um i know kids like i know the parents
have kids who
have gone to school there parkland and
literally kids were murdered
the nightclub in orlando where the guy
went in there and just shot up a gay
club
sandy hook was just so
sad for me i mean i i remember i don't
know any of those kids they were
kindergartners
what was that you know under obama
administration obviously that was in
2013 i want to say i just remember
crying just like what the hell happened
here
obama said that was the angriest he's
ever been
during his uh his tenure his presidency
so what's my point of saying all this
that i've been guilty of saying we got
to do something about the guns
this is [ __ ] ridiculous this is
ridiculous ridiculous
but i'm not an expert on guns like this
is not my wheelhouse but
as a just an american citizen seeing
what happened i mean obviously las vegas
mass murders over there in the
uh columbine the list goes on and on and
on so as it's an american who
gets emotional and i think everyone
should when
mass murders happen you know i've been
guilty of saying well we got to do
something about the guns we got to do
some other guns we got some of the guns
so
where do you find the balance in being a
weapons expert former navy seal you know
someone who knows their stuff
to someone who's just like obviously
acting emotional just being like
you know i'm not saying that the second
amendment should be repealed nothing
ridiculous like
that but you know mentally handicapped
people or people
like accused of a hate crime here or any
of these
issues that biden's pointing out what's
the what's the answer i guess is what
i'm saying but so to me it's actually
pretty simple
is that first of all you you said it is
that emotion is being brought into it
you know and that that's the the first
way to screw up a decision is to let
emotion drive it
so that's number one number two is that
there are so many other statistics that
nobody's talking about and that doesn't
justify
you know deaths via via guns but but
from a data standpoint
when you're talking about quote unquote
mass shootings you're talking about less
than 2 000 people a year
now if one of those 2 000 people as your
son
or a niece or a nephew or or whatever
somebody that you know very well that's
going to that's going to give you some
heartburn
but take malpractice as an example or
you know for
for a tit for tat because malpractice
you know
is is 10 or 20-fold the amount of people
that die who who is screaming about
something needs to be done
to where there are more uh you know
mitigation protocols put in place to
keep people in hospitals from dying
nobody's talking about that
opioid deaths 50 000 or so americans
every single year die from opioid deaths
why isn't
why isn't the the liberal left screaming
about
something has to be done because a lot
of those are kids you know or teenagers
or you know people that get into their
parents percocets nobody's saying
a word about that tit for tat number for
number swimming pools right
on average about 3 500 kids
drown in swimming pools every single
year do you need a swimming pool no you
don't
nobody's saying anything about that more
kids die drowning in swimming pools than
they do in mass shootings now
that's not to discount the fact that
kids shouldn't be
be shot up in schools so that that's the
first thing is that there's a huge
disparity between
the selective outrage of people as it
relates to data and and there are you
know dozens
of data points that that are far more
drastic
and worth worrying about than than kids
being killed by
by mass shootings in the last four years
how many mass shootings have have you
seen covered in the media under the
under a trump presidency as it relates
to eight years of obama
very very few why is that i don't know
what i can say is that it doesn't seem
like it's a just a coincidence but b
and i think more importantly is that the
history of this nation is is built on
on our ability to to exercise that that
freedom that right
in terms of bearing arms but if you look
at say backs
67 years ago you could order weapons
from sears
and have them mailed to you you know it
wasn't uncommon even back
as early as the 70s where kids would
have rifles
in in shotgun rifles and shotguns and
racks in their trucks in the parking
lots there were no problems you know
high schools are
in high schools you know um not the high
school you went to he's just talking
high school
probably not in south florida uh but a
lot of high schools
taught weapons western taught weapon
safety so to me that the two biggest
factors are society and i'm not blaming
one say that one more time that we spoke
over you
a lot of high schools taught yeah many
many high schools back in the 70s and
early 80s
up until about 30 or 40 years ago taught
weapon safety
in high school that's freaking sick
right and so why wouldn't you do it
right so i mean it's like with anything
you you teach how to how to be
off offensive and defensive in terms of
driving you go through driver's ed
why do you think that's something they
need to bring back into the high
you know what for me weapons uh training
absolutely
absolutely i mean it's no it's a piece
of equipment it's a tool no different
than anything else because i'll tell you
right now
they teach how to use a banana no like
with the with condoms they teach how to
use uh
you know how to put a condom on a banana
banana in the tailpipe trick
thanks hawthorne for the uh hand cream
so the old banana
so i mean just like with everything is
you need to understand
what the piece of equipment is you know
and there's there's
let's say that this this table has you
know a hammer a chainsaw
a firearm keys to a rider truck
you know every one of those things can
be used to kill people you know so even
in the hypothetical where you had the
ability to completely remove
every single firearm in this country
okay well i'll use it i'll use a hammer
imagine you know any grown man walking
into a school with a with a 24 inch
steel chainsaw and no firearms with the
ability to defend against that guy
and that's that's an absurd amount of
damage that could be done with that
you could rent a a truck and drive it
through a
parking lot or through a a schoolyard
recess
area during recess and do a reason
anything can be lethal if you put your
course
it's the intent right it's the tool you
know again just
you could reduce it down to the surgeon
but guns obviously
are the best weapon i don't think so i
mean really
i mean let me ask you this do you do you
think right with no training
would you would you be better with a
with a firearm or with a truck
right let's say there's a festival or
it's a you know the fort worth stock
show
right so if you had an ar-15 and body
arm and all
all your mags jammed and ready to go
even though you i'm assuming don't know
a whole lot about how to operate that
or you jump in an f250 right with a lead
foot and you decide i'm going to go mow
some people down at the stock
uh for fort worth stockyards uh or or
the texas state fair
who how many people are you going to
kill without you i see what you're
saying right so
so it's not about the firearm itself
well hopefully there's like
protocol in place like for instance you
could you put
there's a lot of places you drive a car
that there's a lot of traffic if you
really wanted to kill somebody you could
easily do it
and here's the reality is that just like
at tsa right is that at some point
there isn't a protocol there isn't a
mitigation factor you're creating choke
points where
if all these barriers well guess what
people have to line up to get get
through those barriers or those
checkpoints there's always going to be
an area
that's a weak spot where if you wanted
to kill a ton of people
in a variety of mechanisms you would be
able to do it so
while i understand the emotion driven
outrage that people have because it's
it's
it's face value you see a picture of a
seven-year-old cute little girl you know
that you that you know got
shot in the back of the head you know
while while studying english like that's
a shitty deal
there's there's no two ways about it but
what you don't see
is the the 3 500 kids that drowned where
is their picture
where is the 50 000 kids you know that
died from opioid overdoses that nobody's
showing their picture or having a a
ticker that says this is how many how
many kids have died from opioids on
every single media channel
um when you when you talk about you know
just that disparity it's enormous and
the last thing i want to bring up and
then i'll i'll get off my soapbox
is human trafficking all right there's
an
average of about 200 000 kids in this
country
that get roped into into sex slave or
human trafficking that's 200
000 right where is is anybody's outrage
with that
where are their pictures all over the
media where is the hey there was 3 700
kids that were that went missing today
on the side of cnn or on the ticker that
that's nowhere why not
are those kids not not important they
are but but they're not on there so why
not so
you you've got a number of of not not
that 2000 is a small number and again if
it was my daughter would would i be
upset of course i would
you know but but when you when you
contrast it to all of the other problems
and you look at the bandwidth
that's dedicated to to stopping this
problem when there's
huge you know far bigger fish to fry to
me it's just
it's a it's it's a lost cause and i
think you know there's
there's also enough people in this
country that that are absolutely gonna
gonna
give you the come and take it mentality
of saying who's gonna enforce it go
ahead and ban them
come get them and see what happens you
know because whether it's you or it's a
politician somebody that decides that
they're going to say you know these are
illegal
are you going to go take them from from
a guy like me that's that's
barricaded in my house how many police
officers are going to show up and get
smoked
in in a situation like that before the
guys that you're you're
tasking with enforcing it or saying you
know what i'm not doing this [ __ ]
anymore i got a family to feed so
it's a much much more difficult task
than just
making a rule you know if it was as easy
as making a rule
you wouldn't need to do it because
there's already a bunch of rules that
say shooting people
in those capacities is already a felony
so what's your take on all that no
what's your take it's not my take i want
i want to hear from you
what is your response to what he just
said don't worry about what i have
nothing
no i'm on the same page with him i want
to know your exact same page
based on what what part of what he said
can you argue
i'm not i'm not trying to argue but i
want to learn i want to know for
somebody like you
based on what he just said the last
eight minutes how are you processing
what he said
i'm zero percent trying to argue with an
expert on this i have more questions
than points on this straight up i told
you what my
point was initially is that it's very
easy to get emotional like you said
right a seven uh seven-year-old getting
shot up in english class
right who sits there and so i guess
here's my question to you
how can you take the emotion out of it i
i get like the opium the
opioid thing like well you know if
you're 16 years old you choose to
down a bunch of pills you made that
decision if you're sitting in english
class
or doing a nightclub you're sitting in
vegas you you're not making a decision
to take a bunch of pills
you're just living your life so i'm
asking you like how can we take the
emotions out of this how can we use more
logic and most importantly
what protocols can we do because i feel
like this before you answer that going
in circles before you answer that if
you're watching this you agree
100 with more mike said put thumbs up if
you disagree put thumbs down
if you disagree thumbs down explain why
you disagree
with what mike just said the last five
six seven eight minutes go ahead mike
so to me it's not about my level of
expertise on firearms to me
that's completely irrelevant right to me
it's a hundred percent about
i have the ability to remove the emotion
before i start thinking of it and that
has to be self-regulated
right is that i i can't make you control
your own emotions and that's the
one of the biggest byproduct negative
byproducts of cancer culture
is that when you say that offends me or
i don't like to see that or whatever you
know what what what i don't understand
how people don't realize is you are by
default
handing over the control of your
emotions to somebody else
like that is a weak position to have
right
right and so this is no different to me
is that you know don't don't be
spoon-fed by the media and just see well
that's on tv so that's what i should be
worrying about like that's step one
number two is think objectively about
everything again it like i'm not a pool
expert
right i know how to swim i'm not a
swimming pool expert i'm damn sure not a
brain surgeon but i can look at data and
i think
that really is kind of the crux of all
of this is that look at data
because data is not an opinion it's not
a gray area there's nothing to argue
about it is that
this this number of people died from
this this people number of people died
from that
and and then just like like er nurses
and doctors do as they triage is to say
okay
here are our 10 biggest problems in this
country number one is heart disease
let's
talk about that because that's killing
the most people again it does not
trivialize the fact that all these other
people are dying from these other things
but if you're trying to get the most
bang for your buck
it has to be done that way and that can
only that can only be done
by people that have the ability to
regulate their own their own selves that
way
politically speaking um like we see here
in another story that
they freaking run out of ammo gun sales
are up
and there's no not enough not enough
bullets to fill the guns
and you brought up you know under the
trump administration we're not seeing as
many
sensationalized media stories well
i think here's my question though i
think under on obama administration and
certainly what we're seeing under uh
biden forthcoming administration gun
sales skyrocket like you talk about the
industry
you brought up like how many people work
in this industry and jobs and all that
good stuff
under trump sales have gone down
significantly
uh for firearms for fire yeah it's it's
it's
uh i'd love to again i don't know when a
democrat comes into office you have the
stats
yeah i mean i would i would you have the
stats because i have data right here
over the over the last year
uh gun sales have gone up significantly
roof like
you're talking about being sold out and
they have nothing since the election
and by the way here's what you got to be
thinking about one million guns what's
magical about this is he's saying end
the online sale of firearms and
ammunition biden will enact legislation
to prohibit online sales of firearms
ammunition kits and gun parts
the online gun and ammunition industry
in u.s
statistically according to ibisworld.com
is two billion dollar market size
there's 2473 businesses who do
that with 12 326
employees who do that 12 326
jobs who do that so the question i got
for you
is a different question i know what
you're asking him i want to ask you
based on what he explained and he
reasoned with you you
you have the ability to reason how are
you processing the information of what
he just said to you
no i'm processing it very logically and
and with math like you pointed out
the swimming pool example more people
that more kids die
in a swimming pool um
you know than getting shot up so
again i started this entire conversation
off with it's very easy to act
emotionally in these situations if you
don't have emotions when kids get shot
up in sandy hook
go check yourself into a doctor buddy no
but that shouldn't drive your decisions
on how to fix it
right but would you agree that something
can be fixed like for instance the big
debate after vegas was
the bump stock debate yeah they stopped
the sale of bump stocks whatever the
hell
bone stocks right right so i mean again
that makes that bump stock so people
can see what it is because adam needs to
know what a bump stock banning bump
stocks and suppressors and
a certain round of magazines all those
things do is make
no offense but they make people like you
feel better about what their politicians
are not doing
it's really all it is and i'll tell you
why is that air rifles as an example
this is something a lot of people
even in the gun industry aren't that
familiar with
that are not serialized they're not
regulated by the atf
but they have up to 50 caliber um
size munitions that they can shoot with
uh these are you know there's no gun
powder you can make the bullets yourself
uh with a 3d printer or you know a basic
tool and die shop you can you can
machine these types of weapons
it's completely unregulated but it
wouldn't matter if it was because
they're all it's like
you know the macgyver doing [ __ ] in your
kitchen is that all of these materials
are readily available enough to be able
to make them and so
that's half of it right is is that you
know by trying to ban this stuff
it's not going to fix anything the other
thing is that you know
alcohol right prohibition did that work
no it didn't why didn't it because
people decided you know what it's worth
even though i may spend 10 years in
prison i like drinking booze that much
that i'm willing to risk it right i'm
going to make some moonshine in my tub
right so
but that's just that's just booze right
so now imagine
you're scared for your life you've got a
crazy ex
or or you live in a neighborhood where
you know it's getting shot up non-stop
is that you know you're going to do what
you have to do to protect your family if
if you were to ban
and again looking at data if you want to
ban something that's going to try to
make an impact you'd need to ban
handguns
85 90 of all deaths related to firearms
are committed by handguns
so nobody's talking about that either
that's by far the biggest market share
in terms of people that die but
my last point is that let's just say
hypothetically
that you had the ability within all
democratic government
to ban every firearm in existence you
have to get rid of the ones that are
already here
but also what you're going to do is
create an immediate uh
overnight and and incredibly lucrative
black market
for firearms coming through mexico right
it's it's
very easy to get you want to talk about
military weapons grade i mean they have
explosives they have rockets they have
grenades they do some gnarly stuff down
there they don't
you know guns are basically illegal
there they have no problem getting all
that stuff well if they can get people
and drugs in this country almost
unfettered which the liberal policy is
about to change
where they're gonna gonna have the gates
wide open at this point if you if you
don't think that banning guns is now
gonna create
uh a cartel network that's now funneling
weapons into this country you you are
incredibly naive because it will because
they're businessmen
right they they they work in things that
they make money and not just drugs so
uh to me it's a lost cause can you do
something about it yes you can
what you can do is is teach kids how to
respect and operate firearms
and also you use a nuclear family set up
to to give kids
some assemblance of respect for life and
and respect for everything
to me that that is the difference
between now and 70 years ago when guns
were way easier to get a hold of i'll
tell you right now 70 years ago our
grandparents didn't have gun safes
they didn't have fingerprint activated
you know handgun safes under their bed
they had [ __ ] laying around they had
they had it
in the glove box all over the place but
what they did is they taught every one
of their kids to not mess with it the
same way that i'm assuming do you have
kids
no not yet all right so i have kids you
have kids right do you have a kitchen
block with knives in your in your
kitchen plenty do you have power tools
in your garage
plenty right so do you let your kids
mess with those or do you teach them to
respect
them exactly could they kill each other
with with the kitchen block 24 7. could
they grab a hole saw out of the garage
and and punch
a four inch circular hole and then their
brother's cranium yes they could but
they don't because you teach them not to
mess with that stuff and how
to respect it so that's what needs to
happen but by the way
you see this this last 15 minute
discourse the entire country in the
studio needs to listen to this last 15
minutes it's so powerful this last 15
minutes
on the angler went and by the way i want
to continue on this because since we're
already
uh a good mother let me give a quick
shout out to good mother she's given 20
twice first of all saying happy
thanksgiving second time she said the
problem is the mommies
and the government trying to take care
of people and the daddy's letting them
destroy our country
that's what she had to say and we had
another person that just came saying
five dollars seriously children quit the
soy boy nonsense grow up and become real
men if you want adults
to take you seriously okay so that was
by
uh uh also good mother she's still going
at it so let me let me go back to what
you asked about mother sounds like
what what she actually is
a woman she sends messages on instagram
she's probably sent you messages as well
good mother why don't you send a message
to adam so he knows who you are
you asked what we can do about it you
asked what we can do about it and you
know he said a couple different things
one thing you got to be thinking about
is the following what if like
everybody here grew up with a parent
who had a uh uh what's the word who had
a
who was a stickler about something right
what was your mom or dad a stickler
about what were they sticklers about
like it's the weirdest best job no no
i'm talking about like never leave your
shoes outside you know
why are you leaving the soap over here
you know you have to do this with you
turn the lights off turn the lights off
what else was it what what things did
you have what did this clean the
different conditions
what did your parents lose their minds
over what did your parents lose their
minds over do you remember what it was
what was yours
not closing doors not closing doors uh
waking my dad up when he was taking a
nap waking your dad up when he's taking
a nap
because that was pretty crazy right what
else tell me
turn off the lights what do you have
eric losing losing you're losing
every time i had to do a task if i
didn't do it right the first time he
would get really upset he'd be like
do it over again and don't ever [ __ ]
make me check it again that's your dad
shout out to your dad man i like your
dad already
how about yourself anything you had
because you're i mean you come from a
very loving family but yeah
come don't run away when it's time to
whoop your ass with my dad
my dad was an aggressive just right
you're gonna take this ass beaten
here's the point do not run away here's
the take it the point the point i'm
trying to make to you is
now as adults there are certain things
our parents did that haunt us
okay yeah my mom would say she would say
if you bite your nails and you drop them
on the floor your parents are gonna
fight do you want mommy and daddy to
fight
my mom would say if you shoot gum after
the dark you chew in the devil's ear now
think about
this excuse me i'm 42 years old today
right i chew gum at night i have to
throw it away just because my mom told
me when i was six years old if you chew
gum
after the dark you tuned the devil's ear
who the hell says stuff like that and
armenian mother does what they do right
they scare the [ __ ] out of you
what's the point the same way our
parents scare the hell out of us is what
the media is doing whatever the media
chooses
chooses to make their main mo to drive
non-stop emotion out of you and i
they're gonna do it it doesn't matter
what it is if it's to say are you seeing
what these people are doing with the
guns all it takes is one incident to say
this is why we have to ban guns this is
why we have to ban guns i've never seen
anything about pools i've never seen
anything about driving cars i've never
seen anything about knives
i've never seen anything about opioids
you don't hear it when he's talking
about it and i think the part that you
made a lot of sense of the following
this
this is something adam i think you ought
to agree with
you have a show called sauce talks talks
money and you do a great job with your
show that you have sales tax money okay
and you have certain principles six
principles that got you
from being a party guy in miami to being
a millionaire okay in your 30s and
those six tools can those six things
help anybody out can anybody learn from
that i agree now adam let me ask you
this
how many kids in high school should
learn those six things like
which one of those six things do you
think they need to start teaching at
ninth grade eighth grade
okay so now watch this here's stuff that
we don't learn about in school we don't
learn about
marriage we don't learn about what it is
to be married to somebody that
you got married for the wrong reasons we
don't learn about taxes nobody tells us
how to pay the least amount of taxes
possible all they talk about is rich
people don't pay taxes why don't you
teach me how to pay the least amount of
taxes like teaching somebody
how to get the least amount of speeding
tickets how to get the least amount of
felonies misdemeanors
there's nothing wrong with teaching me
how to pay the least amount of taxes
by going out there starting what a
business and having the ability to write
off
they don't teach you about money and
they don't teach you about
guns why don't you teach me about guns
why don't you sit there and train me my
my challenge would be if we ran a
country
here's what i would want if we're
running a country
if we are running a country together my
ideal situation would be
the number i would be tracking is how
many people we have well
trained i want well trained
kids you don't want to join the military
no problem
you do have to take a gun class you
don't want to go in the u.s army i'm all
about some boys that are undecided like
me to go in the military i think it'll
straighten you up and it did to me
army is one of the best decisions i've
ever made you served the military thank
you for your service you were in the
marines
if i don't go in the military i'm not
patrick david i'm somebody else
but if you don't want to go in the
military no problem you got to take a
90-day course on how to use guns
and how to use them properly and how to
learn go learn it
basic stuff why because the more trained
people we have the better it is when i
got my license
driver's license we take a what a
driver's license course you get a permit
and you get a gun at six and then you
get a car at 16 years old if you choose
to do right
i think the the stuff mike talked about
here were so powerful
the the part that concerns me with all
the things that we covered here today
is there's been a everything is now
about
messaging right you know how that one
video shows a hundred different news
stations they're all using the same
script you ever seen that video that
shows all these different guys using the
same script
they have a certain messaging board that
goes as guys this is the line we're
gonna use this is the line we're gonna
use and everybody uses it right
okay buying back guns
we're gonna pay to buy back guns we're
gonna
get rid of you know these semi-automatic
weapons which they have no clue what is
a semi-automatic weapon right we're
going to
try to get rid of bumps we're going to
try to get rid of all this stuff
this is the the consensus based on all
the media that comes together this is
what they talk about when they say
here's
my question is going to be what what is
really going to happen
if they decide to push hardcore to do
get
guns back and buying back what do you
think the people are going to do in
america do you think they're just going
to say
okay cool let me just give it back to
them or i think there's going to be a
reaction
i think there's going to be it's going
to be measured based on how into them
you are
you know for for the average guy that
has you know maybe a pistol and maybe a
shotgun
is like man i don't want to get wrapped
up into you know pushing the envelope
and whatever he'll probably turn him in
then there's going to be the people at
the other end of the spectrum where
there are fanatics about it uh and i'll
tell you myself as an example like
there's a few guns that that i have that
aren't worth having anymore that if they
said hey we're doing a buy back i'd be
like sweet
here's the five ones i don't give a [ __ ]
about you can take them back and i'll
take my thousand bucks or whatever how
many guns do you have mike
enough we'll just put it at that but
more than a few dozen
no i'm not i'm not a fanatic about it i
mean i i have a handful of pistols a
handful of rifles a handful of shots
what do you think about these people
that have
30 40 50 100 freaking guns well i mean
same thing with watches with shoes with
vehicles with
houses you know to me america should be
this it should be free
right and and whether or not you think i
should own anything
is no more more your business than
whether or not i think you should own
whatever the hell you own i don't care
what you own i think you should own
whatever you want to me freedom
and i've said this on a number of times
people are going to laugh i think
freedom
is like being pregnant right and that
sounds ridiculous but
the reality of it is is you can't be
kind of pregnant or mostly pregnant or
almost completely pregnant
right you either are or you're not and
with great freedom
comes great responsibility it's it's big
boy rules and you've got to learn how to
how to manage that
right but i i would much rather live in
a society where shit's dangerous
uh you know and people have the autonomy
to make decisions the same way that i
think kids should be raised is give them
the ability to make stakes mistakes
don't micromanage them and
decide everything for them because it
builds resentment and it creates
sneakiness
for anybody out there that has kids the
harder you are on them what happens they
find a way around it the same way they
do in prison the same way they do in
sears school the same way they do in
boot camp
you know what's what's not allowed in
prison cell phones
drugs cigarettes ass rape guess what
happens in prison all of those things
right so so well bear with me right
right we live in a society where
we have elements of our government that
are trying to say we're going to control
you as
stringently as prison but guess what
if in a prison-like environment you
can't keep those things out of prison
where it's as controlled as you can
possibly control a group of human beings
how on earth do you do do you logically
try to reason with people
and and think that it that you're
realistically going to be able to do
that in a somewhat free society it's not
going to happen
it's the prohibition moonshine analogy
right there like when there's a world
there's a way
right or let's let's take meth right
methamphetamines
all 50 states methamphetamines is a
federal felony right
except oregon now at a certain amount
the other 49.
all right you with 300 at any gas
station in any state within about 25
minutes you can get a hold of some
right well it's illegal it's a federal
felony you'll spend a lot of time in
prison if you have it but it's still
that easy to get hold of
what makes anybody think that guns are
going to be any different that way
like if people are are that that into to
drugs or to booze or to whatever it is
that they want ivory
you know ivory's illegal people have
ivory you know i mean it's just
pick anything that that is that is
illegal and and show me where it
actually
doesn't exist i i challenge anybody
listening out there
show me one area prison or otherwise
where something is is a
banned federal felony where with a few
hundred dollars and a couple hours of
your free time that you can't get a hold
of it at anywhere in this country
in a democratic society i assume you
mean i mean obviously even in a
socialist or communist
or you know take china it's the same
thing you think black markets don't
exist there like
they run a way tighter ship than we do
guess what you can get anything in china
right so so show me even like nobody
wants to live like china but even in
china you can get anything there
right so so how are you going to do that
here you're not
human nature dictates that people will
find a way i'm going to use another jeff
goldblum no question about them
life will find a way this is this is now
this is jurassic park you're bringing
drugs i'm doing it again
maybe i've got a thing for jeff goldblum
i think uh you had a jeff goldblum
reference recently with him
there's a resemblance yeah no no no no
where
pat's with the glasses yeah where are
the glasses with the glasses maybe
somewhere well
you were saying no but but that's life
will find a way people will find a way i
mean you know human beings are the most
ingenuitive species by a lot that's why
we're where we're at
right but that that applies to
everything not just for the good for the
bad look again look at prison look at
gangs look at
look at pow camps in vietnam look at the
[ __ ] that some of those guys were able
to pull off right being tortured every
day
being you know chained to a wall and
they still managed to pass notes to each
other i mean
people will find a way around everything
it's just you know to me the
the answer is you know it's the adage
you catch more
flies with honey than you do vinegar
like instead of trying to outlaw
everything teach people how to do it
right you know
i mean and that's with everything it's
it's not just with guns it's
it's with you know how to conduct
yourself like pat was saying like how to
do taxes how to treat
treat your spouse how to you know how to
do basic
human things that you should learn how
to do that people aren't being taught in
in uh elementary in high school
well look let me say mike i i actually
listened
you know i used the two years uh in my
head no not emotional i
i i took this this segment this
opportunity to learn something here you
know
and i appreciate what you have to say
and it's opened my mind on this topic
for sure
i appreciate it so um much respect for
laying out the good mother gave you five
bucks and she said
leave adam alone he's at least asking
questions because he's curious so
good mother's on your side do you feel
like i'm not looking for sides i'm just
i'm trying to get your mother is
trying to support you here and you're
taking shots at her and good mother i'm
not jumping on adam we're just we're
just talking do you feel like we're
doing good no not even a little
bit we're having by the way honestly
this has been such
great banter on this topic but let's
let's talk about what you were talking
about off camera
regarding when's the last time we heard
anything about terrorism isis why don't
you want to talk about that a little bit
i just i found it interesting that you
know leading up to the 2016 election
uh we were inundated with isis you know
that i mean
again it's what the media decides to uh
to show you right and i think that that
that speaks volumes right is that you
know a scared
public the the the masses being
frightened by something
makes them tend to vote or or at least
have the opinion of
certain people can handle it better and
i think that that was probably a tactic
you know it was pretty often where you
know on nightly news
pic pick a program where you would see
you know a map of
syria iraq and and there's you know red
and green versus
you know what what isis holds versus not
or whatever and
now four years or almost four years into
the trump presidency when was the last
time
whether it's leading up to the election
or even in the last couple of years
where any of the media has ever
portrayed any
negative aspect to what's going on
foreign policy-wise or isis
terrorist-wise
there's been zero you know to me that
that's an interesting thing because the
the 2016 election
like most of what we were talking about
going into it in 2012 even more so
uh you know that drove a lot of the
debates a lot of the policy a lot of you
know people's voting positions was
foreign policy and now it's it's
it's basically void uh you know that the
media is void of any foreign policy
discussions whatsoever in the last
couple years and
you know to me that that's worth talking
about regarding isis you're saying
regarding everything i mean because
there's there's been there's been
attacks in france you know where
terrorists have gone into into uh
cathedrals and sliced the throats of
uh well that was very recent right and
yeah or i was covered
i heard all about that on what channel i
mean that was out there a few weeks ago
i mean
out there on the income for sure how
much time was dedicated to that versus
everything else that you hear
well let me just say this clearly i mean
would you agree that
isis and the caliphate was a way bigger
problem in 2015 than it is now
well i mean i thought that was what i
mean and kudos to trump
no i mean well dude you figured it out i
mean i you know i don't even know if
it's
necessarily a media thing more other
than just actual fact thing
where we defeated isis let me ask you
this for the most part
back in 2015 how was your life impacted
by terrorism other than what you heard
on the
media versus now i mean valid point i
don't think any most people in america
are getting
beheaded on the weekend you know and uh
right but but in an isis beheading but
just like however but it was more
prevalent more rampant
five years ago i think you heard it you
heard about it a lot more if you think
that there isn't still a bunch of
terrible [ __ ] happening in iraq and
syria and kurdistan and everywhere else
right now
it is dude mike no freaking doubt was it
was there drama going on in afghanistan
and iraq and yemen and is there
no fight's been going on no doubt but
are you saying that over the last five
years we've done nothing to
defeat isis no we absolutely have okay
my point is
is that what you're hearing about it
though is almost non-existent the same
way
what are the stats that now all of a
sudden that you were like holy [ __ ] i
wasn't aware of that swimming pools
right yeah yeah yeah opioid deaths those
are all things that have been taking
place year after year human trafficking
same thing
you haven't heard any about any of that
those data wise
impact our society and our children the
next generation
far greater than coronavirus does you
know
from a lethality standpoint i mean i
mean hands down children for sure
right so but you're not hearing about
that you didn't hear about that
is your ultimate point here that a lot
of this is uh
sensationalism 100 it is okay you know
you would have known about 200 000 human
traffickers
you would have known about 3 500 kids
drowning in why does the media cover
human trafficking you brought that up a
few times why is that not a topic
that doesn't seem like a political topic
i mean from my perspective i think that
there are enough people
that are that are in the hierarchies of
the upper echelons of hierarchy at some
of these media groups that are complicit
to it because they're probably involved
in it
that's what i think hold on back up yeah
unpack that last part
it's exactly what i said to me i i can't
come up or rationalize
any other excuse as to why that
with that kind of data that nobody is
saying anything about it
other than the fact that they're at
least okay with it
i mean you tell me why it is i would
pose the same question
those numbers i mean look it up right
it's on government websites the amount
of people that are trafficked
and in fact i took a screenshot uh out
screenshot of it on the way over here
but is it is it are they talking about
it let me
are they talking about it is it across
the board meaning are they bringing it
up more on
newsmax and oan and nobody versus cnn
no nbc you don't hear it on any of them
so it's not necessarily like if you're a
liberal democrat you're into
making kids but if you're a conservative
you're not like no which tells me
you're
or what is this i don't know anything
about it i'm not a q anon guy i'm not a
i'm not a tinfoil hat guy i'm not an
alex jones guy
to me i i'm an emotional uh patriot as
it relates to
uh you know where my emotions get fed
into it that's being passionate about
this country what is that tin foil stuff
with the q and on stuff
i don't know i mean you're asking the
wrong guy like legitimately i don't know
maybe maybe adam needs to go on alex
jones and they need to do something
together why don't we have alex jones
here on the show
you and alex would hit it off do you
think we can get alex jones around here
i think we just have to make a phone
call we just haven't made that phone
call
one eight hundred queuing on he shows up
how does that work okay
i mean i again say that i'd love to see
the two of you guys go at it man it
would be so entertaining i have a lot of
questions
i'm sure you do
you